si vous utilisez un smartphone de
Samsung et que vous êtes amoureux de
selfie il faut absolument que vous
regardez cette astuce vous venez si dans
votre application photo et vous passez
en mode selfie coucou c'est moi avant
c'était la galère pour venir trouver les
filtres directement ici dans votre
application photo maintenant vous les
avez juste en haut à droite ça c'est une
nouveauté sur mon réveil 5.1 là vous
avez directement vos filtres chauds
froid clair givré fleurs ivoire tamisée
Kiss Me gris black and white vignette
bref il y en a des tonnes ils sont juste
là des réglages aussi au niveau de votre
visage vous pouvez venir agrandir la
taille de vos yeux si vous le souhaitez
les rétrécir la mâchoire plus large
moins large on se profile davantage on
peut modifier le teint directement c'est
assez doux comme réglage la finesse
également vous voyez donc on a pas mal
de petites options qu'on peut venir
utiliser directement ici je serai très
chouette c'est plus clair plus lisible
une fois de plus d'ailleurs est-ce que
vous connaissez cette astuce est-ce
qu'elle vous intéresse est-ce qu'elle
vous plaît oui non marquez moi ça dans
les commentaires